it's going to be up to governments to
try to rein in
uh the disinformation this is a
temporary ban
it will likely be uh if we're fortunate
a permanent ban
these folks don't give a damn about
democracy are you kidding me it's
insanity
so you have jen sackey saying that it's
the responsibility of these big tech
companies to quote unquote stop
misinformation number one that's just
not true
it's not true okay these big tech
companies are platforms the whole point
of them
is that it is not their job to police
what's in the comments section 230 of
the communications decency act was
specifically designed
to protect companies so that those
companies would not be held liable
legally for the stuff posted on their
website so now they're just reversing
this
right now they're going to say that
facebook ought to be held responsible
for stuff that a third party posts on
facebook which completely defeats the
purpose
of open threads it defeats the purpose
of comment sections it defeats the
purpose of youtube
and twitter and facebook it destroys
them wholesale if they are responsible
for the material
that appears on their platforms then
this means that they are effectively the
same as the new york times or the daily
wire they are just editorial sites
that's number one number two
when she says that we want them to crack
down on misinformation with regard to
coveted elections
let's just note here that the biden
administration has routinely lied about
both covenant and elections
the biden administration has suggested
over and over and over again
that georgia's new voter laws are jim
crow that is an overt lie it is an
abject disgusting overt lie those laws
are in many ways more permissive with
regard to voting than for example new
york
or new jersey there's no one who has a
shred of sanity who believes
that those laws look anything like jim
crow the great lie the democrats have
been promoting that voter suppression
has been deciding elections
it is a lie but they don't want that lie
shut down they want that lie promulgated
they want that lab promoted they want it
trumpeted from the highest rooftop so
they can pretend to black americans
that the gop is trying to shut down
their rights
so those sorts of lies they want
promoted it just depends on the
misinformation and when it comes to
covid
i can't think of a bigger purveyor of
coven misinformation in this
administration
they keep just saying stupid crap that
makes no sense about masking
and outdoor standards and the efficacy
of the vaccines it's just ridiculous on
every level
but this is the the going push by the
folks
on the left the going pushes shut down
dissemination of information it's what
they want
this is authoritarian stuff yeah i have
a new book coming out called the
authoritarian moment it comes out in
july one of the things that i discuss
is one of the reasons that the left
wants to keep focusing on january 6th
because generous six was really terrible
it was a terrible terrible event for the
country
but the reason they want to keep their
focus on january 6th is to
overlook the fact that the reaction to
january 6th on the left
is significantly more authoritarian than
the actual effect of january 6th
on january 6th a bunch of authoritarians
went in and tried to overturn the
legitimate results of an election
that's true and it was it was like
several hundred idiots and then they
were immediately cleared out and then a
bunch of republicans certified the
election
it was over the major institutions in
american life
the biggest most powerful institutions
in american life are attempting to
destroy your ability to disseminate
information
to see information they're attempting to
destroy your ability to raise your child
as you see fit
they're looking to destroy your business
if you fail to comply with their woke
standards
the authoritarian movement in the united
states is not chiefly from the right
this doesn't mean there aren't
authoritarians on the right there are
but the authoritarian movement in the
united states the dangerous
authoritarianism that we experience in
everyday life and at every level of
american society
is coming from the institutional heads
inside blue america
like i don't know what to say about the
fact that hillary clinton who is
secretary of state and senator from new
york and nearly the president of the
united states
she's out there saying yeah yeah i know
this is great big tech needs to shut
down trump or
we should shut down big tech okay this
is just authoritarian stuff
there must be a reckoning by the tech
companies for
the role that they play in undermining
the information
ecosystem uh that is absolutely
essential for the functioning of any
democracy
and it's going to be up to governments
and i would even hope some global rules
but let's start with
governments to try to rein in uh the
disinformation
uh on the uh social media platform
first of all that should scare the
living hell out of you when hillary
clinton and democrats start talking
about global governance
what we want zimbabwe's input and how
information gets disseminated
this is one of the big problems for
facebook facebook is a global company
what they should be doing is
promulgating first amendment american
standards
they are not they're seeking explicitly
to have other governments regulate them
because they don't know what to do
because otherwise they're held liable
in places like germany for speech
they're not liable for in places like
the united states so when you say
when hillary clinton says we need an
international global standard on free
speech
understand that's what we're talking
about here the idea that government's
job is to rein
in the dissemination of information is
precisely the reverse of the first
amendment it is precisely the opposite
of the first amendment
and the fact that they've gotten all
these social media companies to
basically do this stuff voluntarily
under threat
just demonstrates that essentially
they're using these major corporations
as their agents
we are now operating not in a free
market capitalist america with regard to
social media we are operating in a
corporatist america with regard to
social media where they are given
special privileges by the government
and then the government tells them all
you have to do is implement standards
that we like
about information that we don't like
adam schiff
one of the great purveyors of
misinformation for years right i mean
this douchebag
was on msnbc every single day talking
about how
the other shoe was going to drop it was
going to come out that trump was was
actually peeing on russian prostitutes
or they were peeing on him and
all of this was it was all russian
collusion the the evidence would show up
sooner or later
here is adam schiff saying that he hopes
that the ban from facebook is permanent
on trump
of course he does the president here is
continuing to go out and push the big
lie
about the election continuing i think to
to
endanger our democracy by doing that
and so he continues to make the case uh
that he would violate the policies
if they readmitted him and i think
frankly
pathologically he's incapable of
changing
so this is a temporary ban it will
likely be
if we're fortunate a permanent ban
because the president is not going to
stop the lies about the last election or
lies about the next one he will incite
people
i swear i don't want to hear about
authoritarianism from a group of people
who are using their perch in government
to attempt to literally stop a political
opponent from being able to speak
i mean that is the essence of
authoritarianism what you're watching
right now from the white house from
congress from hillary clinton
from this whole cadre of the mainstream
establishment left
is we want to use the methods of
informational dissemination to shut
down our political opponents and once
you threaten them to do it
we're going to threaten these companies
in order to make that happen and give
them special privileges and pat them on
the head if they're good little boys and
girls
it's insanity but we're told that the
authoritarianism is on the right
the hell it is by the way not to be
self-serving here but the reality is
this is one of the reasons why you
should go subscribe to the services that
you love right now because at any moment
this entire tsunami of authoritarianism
nonsense
could be pushed against anybody
including places you like i could push
against staley wire it could be pushed
against my show
go subscribe right now over at daily
wire because again you want to protect
the content that you love because i
don't trust these people do you
i don't trust these tech companies are
going to stand up to the overwhelming
tsunami of authoritarian nonsense being
pushed
by the establishment left and there's
the establishment left this is not
and it's amazing how fast the
liberal movement caved in the united
states to this this insane censorious
left
how many liberals are left to stand up
to this how many liberals still stand
for the
original principles of like the aclu how
many people still believe
i'm i remember in the 90s people used to
say i'm left all the time
this was their their great this was
their great civil liberties moment they
would say things like
i may not agree with you but i will
defend to the death your right to say
what you want to say
right remember do you remember dissent
is the height of patriotism remember
this during the iraq war
no longer now according to the
establishment left you disagree with us
and we will find a way to shut you down
including by the way the sitting
president of the united states at the
time we will find a way
to stop you from speaking and it would
be one thing if they had any sort of
articulable standard
that is consistently applied but there
is no articulable standard that's
consistently applied
the biden administration routinely lies
the binding administration routinely
says things that are untrue democrats
members of the media have openly
defended
acts of violence depending on who is
committing the act of violence none of
them have been banned
so what this really is is just about
power it's so funny the entire
deconstructionist movement
the sort of philosophical
deconstructionist movement is about the
idea that there are no centralizing
principles everything is just a power
game
right then when people talk about
freedom and equality when people talk
about the principles of the declaration
of independence they're lying
that really all that was was a guise for
power it's all just a facade
right it's a way for rich white men to
cram down their own version of the
system
it's all projection okay
deconstructionism from the establishment
left
is just product projection because for
them there are no universal principles
it is just
about power there are no universal
principles that apply to your rights
there are no universal principles that
apply
to the level of misinformation that can
be disseminated there's nothing
consistent here it is just about what
they can get away with and what kind of
power they can use
in order to apply pressure that's all
and that's authoritarian there's no
other word for it
okay what we are watching right now
again this is not just a picture of my
book but it is a picture my book the
book the
is the authoritarian moment you can go
pre-order it right now on amazon because
i go through all of this in detail
they have renormalized america's
institutions in order to silence
everyone they disagree with
and they are doing it with big tech
right now and so for people on the right
who are like yeah there's a
wide right left agreement that we need
to shut down big tech no they disagree
for completely dif
they they don't like big tech for
completely different reasons the right
wants big tech to consistently apply any
standard hopefully
a very broad free speech standard the
left once you simply run these companies
the left simply wants to make sure that
you cannot speak that you cannot share
that you are not allowed to to have
organic reach with the stories that you
push that you never see the information
they don't want you to see
most obvious example being that hunter
biden story the new york post
twitter account shut down a month before
the election because of a true hunter
biden story
facebook shutting it down preventing the
dissemination of even the link you
couldn't even link to it
and you watch this is the next move what
you will see is that now that donald
trump
has started his quasi blog on his page
the next move by twitter and facebook
will be
you are not allowed to tweet any link
from that blog
because again this is not about freedom
it is not about protecting democracy
these folks don't give a damn about
democracy are you kidding me
they want to completely rewrite the
rules of the game they want to
completely federalize every election
procedure in the united states they want
to make ballot harvesting legal
they want to make sure that voter id
cannot be put into law
and then they want to cram a bunch of
seats into the senate
in undemocratic fashion in order to
stack the system
in favor of their own political
priorities they don't give a damn about
democracy or the procedures of the
constitution
it's all just a power game in the end
it's all about power for the
establishment left there are
no principles if you are if you're a
believer that there are principles from
the same people who are saying that
misinformation has to be shut down on
the internet but we can lie as much as
we want
i don't know what to tell you they are
unprincipled it is just power
i know what you're thinking it's time to
bin some more ben shapiro videos well
you are right
you should but first like and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video